were you surprised by some of the
performances you mentioned a couple of
names there nakamura for example for
sure i think everybody was surprised
because
everybody thought uh okay we are jealous
of icaru he's the most handsome he's the
richest
he beats everyone in blitz
but at least at least
he's not good classical
you know
at least he's not good at classical
you know
but no
so you have to really be fully jealous
it was his first classical game in over
two years i believe so yeah
i was performance i was not as much
surprised as some of my younger friends
who were not really
there uh following top chess from up
close
and for them hikaru is a guy who was
once top player whatever
and is an online god or whatever
but i saw hikaru at his prime i was
playing this tournament i was playing
against him aspiring as him and i i saw
that this is a top player i know this is
a top player he's monstrously strong
right he is very strong and i just saw
it i experienced it
and i was turning to these guys who are
like when i speak to them to the young
guys you know
they
don't understand who we talk about they
speak about some other guy and i i knew
that he's very good
and i i thought that okay maybe that
that died that that part of him
that i knew but it seems that it was
just sleeping so you think that side or
the old hikari will come back now after
it can wake up i guess
i i think that every top player unless
he's really old and unless he stops just
entirely
can always come back and always wake up
yeah because these skills that you have
to be a strong chess player
they're so deeply in great calculation
skill and understanding
and these are such deep skills that just
never
they just never dissipate so